it's market day in you building an unlit
constants in southern Germany
conventional and organic farmers are
proud of their offerings here the fruit
and vegetables are one hundred percent
natural and one hundred percent gm-free
forecast and Fritz it's important to
live and eat healthily and she says
that's only possible if Germany remains
free of genetically modified crops
there's no scientific evidence yet to
show what genetically modified food
actually does to you as long as that's
not established i would say stay clear
of genetic engineering and the local
authorities agree with the people in
their region you burlington declared
itself GM free ten years ago before any
other community in germany local mayor's
abena becca says that the anti-gm stance
is shared across the political spectrum
vm i stop we have a lot of land as a
city and we lease a lot of it out to
farmers but only on condition that no
genetic engineering is used if this were
to happen they would lose their lease
I'm suzette sanitize display Van [ __ ]
dugongs Kunta Park fleshy
so in this idyllic part of southern
Germany no GM dung is allowed on the
fields no GM fodder is allowed to be
given to animals and most hotels and
restaurants in the region support the
anti-gm movement the European Union's
decision to approve the cultivation of
genetically modified maize 1507 earlier
this year has outraged many locals they
are particularly angered by the German
government support which means the maze
could soon be farmed in Germany yet most
German states opposed the GM crop page
every dish represents the state of
baden-württemberg in the EU he's
campaigning on behalf of the state's
ruling coalition of greens and Social
Democrats give one gets a version thus
we want to ensure that decisions on
whether crop can or cannot be farmed are
taken at national level we want to be
able to say we do not want this
particular product this particular crop
here with national autonomy would sag on
here inside each in that's another
autonomy that one's neat recent polls
say that eighty eight percent of germans
opposed genetically modified food but
not everybody in germany's against
biotechnology some say it has its
advantages garrett vibha is a retired
professor of biotechnology who believes
the fear surrounding GM crops is
unfounded angle disarmament vices of a
good argument that has been proven by
twenty years of farming across the world
is that there is less use of
insecticides that's funny thing this
means a farmer can produce in a more
efficient way the daughters of a fern
lund vert those if it's enter put its
income but at this organic farm in your
building and no one is convinced
marching hun is a Green Party member of
the state parliament as well as a farmer
he has no faith at all in genetic
engineering as gig VI neehoff some hope
it will improve agriculture that it'll
improve yields but the fact is that
we're dealing with a risky technology
that we do not need
and that is the crux of the matter when
this is the end time to pull so far the
issue is kept germany's grand coalition
divided but here christian democrat
mayor Zebina becca completely agrees
with martin han and the Green Party she
says that Berlin has to realize how
dangerous it would be to approve GM
crops in Germany indication if genetic
engineering is permitted if one single
genetically modified product is approved
it will be the point of no return and
that's what causes most fear that
something will be put into motion and we
won't be able to defend ourselves
against it bud and rittenberg is hoping
the anti-gm camp will prevail otherwise
this market will no longer be able to
guarantee one hundred percent natural
food